[Applause]
hi everyone thank you for having me so
I'm gonna do more than just talk about
investor meetings I also want to talk
about who the investors are that you're
gonna be raising money from maybe one
day and what motivates them because in
order to have a good meeting you need to
know what you're doing and how to
achieve that goal so when we think about
investor meetings there's a question of
when you need them who you need them
with how to actually get the meetings
and actually how to do the meetings this
might seem weird but a meeting isn't
just walking into a room and sitting
across the table from someone staring
into each other's eyes you need to
actually talk you need to make points
and you need to know what points to make
and kirstie just ran you through the
debt the the mechanics of what
fundraising actually means but in order
to actually get the money from somebody
you usually have to know they are track
them down find them convince them to
meet with you convince them to give you
money and then get the money in the bank
so there's a lot of steps that come up
ahead of time so this is going this this
talk is kind of your magical plan to
automatically raise money if you follow
these tips no one will ever say no to
you if they do it's your fault all right
so the first thing is figuring out when
you actually need to raise money right
not every business needs money MailChimp
famously has never raised a dollar an
outside financing and is worth billions
of dollars
so before you think about whether or not
you or or before you think about meeting
with investors to raise money you first
need to answer the question of if you
actually need to raise money and there's
a bunch of different steps in this you
can raise money when you're just at the
idea stage you can raise money if you
just have a prototype you can raise
money when you have users in fact it
gets easier and easier as you have each
of these things because they're
demonstrations of progress but you need
money when you actually need it to grow
your business and figuring out whether
or not you need money to grow your
business is a very particular decision
about your company so if you think about
this think about raising money as a
continuum right if you have nothing and
no understanding of how you would spend
money if you had it
don't try to raise money it's a waste of
time instead focus on building your
product and building your company if you
get a little further along you have your
idea or your prototype you start to see
oh if I actually had a little more money
I'd be able to do X Y & Z which would
make me go faster now flip yourself into
the mind of the investor and think about
okay well if I'm an investor why am i
giving this person money I have to have
a reason right and the reason is because
I expect it to be very very very large
one day and I also expect them to be
able to use this money appropriately
there are some uses that are good for
money and some uses that I would say are
bad the first thing people always say
about why they need to raise money is
they need to hire employees this is very
attractive because companies love to
talk about how many employees they have
it's a great metric when you don't have
revenue or actual progress but the truth
is because you are building startups
which hopefully leverage software you
need to hire far fewer people than you
think you do and in fact hiring is the
single best way to kill your company if
you don't need to do it because people
cost money and so if you are already
hiring you already need money whether or
not your idea is any good whether or not
your idea is growing so think very
careful about carefully about whether or
not the blocker between you and the next
step of growth is actually hiring the
next thing people love to say is well we
need to do user acquisition we need to
spend money on Google Ads
this is usually a very bad way to grow
your business especially early you start
spending money on Google ads and you
start looking at your user numbers and
say look are you
numbers are growing up so we need to
pour more money into it and what many
people don't think especially if it's
their first startup is whether or not
they're acquiring people profitably
customers profitably and whether or not
they're doing that profitably on a
timeline that allows them to recycle
capital and keep growing so before you
start spending money on user acquisition
it probably makes sense to start
acquiring people for free get users who
love your product to tell their friends
about how much they love the product and
then you get them for free and you don't
need to raise money then some of you
will need customer service if your
customers are getting angry because
you're not doing enough to make them
happy you're not answering their
questions that's actually a pretty good
reason to raise money and is actually
one of the first limiting factors that a
lot of companies hit and the reason this
is a good one is because you as founders
will be able to deal with customer
service for quite a long time and you'll
only stop being able to do that when you
have enough users and customers that you
get overwhelmed and what's interesting
is that if someone's using a product
that is free their expectation of
customer service is much lower which
means you can handle a lot more and if
they're paying you your customer service
that level has to be higher but you're
making more money so you can afford to
hire more people to do customer service
before you actually have to look for
outside capital now part of the reason
I'm saying and warning so actively
against fundraising before you're ready
is the earlier you raise money the more
diluted that capital is right people
aren't going to give you a 5 a 3 million
dollar valuation a 5 million dollar
valuation a 10 million dollar valuation
unless you have something to show them
so every dollar raised is more of your
equity in your eventual multi-billion
dollar business that you're giving away
you don't want to do that if you don't
have to let's talk a little bit about
the types of investors in your
neighborhood first we have friends and
family then there are accelerators there
are angels
there are seed funds there are VC funds
and there's crowdfunding there are so
many different ways to raise money in so
many different places
from which to raise it but the important
thing in figuring out who these
investors are how to get meetings with
them and how to convince them that they
should actually give you money is
understanding a little bit about them
what motivates them and how to get in
touch with them so first let's talk
about accelerators accelerators are
basically investors that have education
programs attached to them YC is an
accelerator right we take you in for
three months we work with companies we
try to make them better and better and
better and better and better by teaching
them what we know and helping them avoid
mistakes and then we launch them out
into the world in demo day and give them
a community on the other side now there
are thousands of accelerators all over
the world we see applications from all
over the world and I think the number of
accelerators is proliferating faster
than the number of startups and this
terrifies me because most of the people
who are advising companies in
accelerators have no idea what they're
doing
they've never worked at a startup
they've never started a startup
they've never funded a start-up outside
of the accelerator you got to ask
yourself why on earth should I take
advice from this person who's never done
any of the things that they're telling
me I should do never gotten never seen
any of these things work and actually
what you notice is most accelerators
actually hurt companies so be very
careful about going to an accelerator
none of you need an accelerator to
succeed as a company if the accelerator
is helpful that's great but if not it
damages your company because of the word
accelerate if you do an accelerator come
out the other side and you were the same
or worse than you were when you started
it didn't accelerate you very well did
it and every other investor that looks
at you will look at you and think huh
that didn't work
what's it actually going to take to the
accelerate this company it's probably
not money there must be something wrong
with the founders and it might not be
you it might have been the accelerator
right that hurt you so be careful and
think very carefully and look at the
track
record that those accelerators have next
up friends and family this is probably
the most common source of funding for
early-stage startups at the earliest
earliest stages friends and family are
moms dads rich uncle's Grammy and
pop-pop people who have hopefully a
little bit of extra money that they can
give you because it feels good let's be
honest your friends and family don't
usually think you're going to build the
next Google right they love you they
remember when you were in diapers and
they're basically giving you money
because you have conviction that you can
do something and they want to support
you and be nice don't take advantage of
that niceness only take money from
friends and family if you know that they
can afford to lose every single dollar
that they give you because let's be
honest you're probably gonna lose every
single dollar they give you let that
sink in most startups that raise venture
capital do not produce a return so be
very thoughtful about whether or not you
take money from friends and family and
don't make the terms really really
onerous don't raise $50,000 from your
grandma at a 50 million dollar valuation
it doesn't make any sense you're
probably gonna get the inheritance
anyway so it just doesn't work but
seriously if you artificially set a very
high price at this point in your life
you can probably set the price because
again they're being nice but that makes
every other fundraising you do
increasingly difficult because the price
is so high when you do want money from a
friend or a family member
treat it like a real meeting treat them
as if they're real investors be
respectful of their time going with an
actual pitch and an actual understanding
of what you're doing not just can you
please give me money now thank you right
don't do that really treat this as a as
an important thing because it'll help
train you for the next stage of raising
money which is usually angels angels are
basically rich people with a little too
much time and money
their hands they invest mostly as a
sport all right have you ever noticed on
Twitter angels will often say oh my
billion dollar company this my billion
dollar company that it's basically
trophy hunting right you have no idea
how much money they invested in those
companies or whether or not they
actually made money or whether or not
the money that they made is meaningful
to them but they really like to invest
in new companies and there's actually a
lot of reasons it's actually not just
about trophy hunting there's a lot of
angels who invest because they really
want to see new technologies exist or
because when they were new founders
someone gave them a chance and they want
to pay it forward
angels are usually pretty easy to get in
front of because they well professional
angels are easy to get in front of all
they want to do is invest in exciting
new interesting companies and spend time
with founders who make them feel
interested right and who teach them
things so email them and if they seem
really really busy
you can usually network to them pretty
quickly especially if they're local
whatever city you're in pretty much
around the world has at least a few
Angels the one last thing I would say
about angels is that you should be
careful of angel groups forget what
they're called but there are basically
these groups of angels that like to get
together for meals and grilled new
founders and then not invest and it's
the sport of ripping people apart
because they're successful investors or
something and they just want to show you
how good they are so before you take
money from or before you go chase an
angel down do some research ahead of
time to figure out whether or not they
actively invest that's the signal have
they made an investment in the last six
months 12 months five years ten years
they haven't made an investment in a
year - they're probably not investing
actively so it's probably not a good
idea to waste your time chasing them
down next up the cow
stack is seed funds seed funds are kind
of super professional angels who have
raised some amount of the outside
capital that they are investing they're
usually investing on behalf of angels
who maybe don't have enough money to be
lp's in really big funds
these are usually newer but professional
investors who are trying to learn the
ropes
they're often great they're often recent
founders they're probably pretty
aggressive about finding good deals they
have quick processes because they know
they have to move quickly do research on
them their whole job is to meet new
founders who they want to talk to and
invest in so email them cold emails to
these people are fine if you can get a
warm email great but you should just
reach out to seed funds their entire job
is meeting with you to see if they can
invest in you and remember that they are
investing for a return so that they can
raise their next fund so they're not
interested in things that are just going
to produce a small return they're not
interested in lifestyle businesses which
an angel might be interested in
investing in if there's cash flow they
need you to return capital then there's
the VC funds these are obviously the the
big deal in fundraising VC funds run the
gamut their VC funds that invest
million-dollar checks and their VC funds
that invest billion-dollar checks
know what you need for your stage of
capital they all have or almost all have
multiple LPS which are limited partners
will give them money and say hey we need
you to produce X percent return on an
annual basis it's called an IRR target
and these people these LPS are looking
across all the venture funds in the
world and saying where can i allocate
money and then they're looking at all of
the different alternative asset managers
and saying where can i allocate money
and then they're looking across all of
investable assets and saying where can i
allocate money and so if i'm a VC
partner if I'm a GP I have to think not
only do I have to be one of the better
VCS
I have to return more at a better risk
than anything else this investor could
put money into for me to get that LP
capital so when they're looking
you they don't just need you to return
five or 10x they're looking at every
single investment saying will this
investment return my entire fund so as
you're thinking about how to meet with
these people right you got to think
about
oh shoot when I walk into that meeting I
can't just pitch a small vision of what
I'm doing I got to do something big here
now VC is when they invest usually have
a pretty specific structure of what they
do and how they make decisions you might
be with a partner at first and then two
partners and five partners and then the
whole general partnership if you're
raising something like a Series A but
the earlier stages most of the bigger VC
funds can make a decision off a meeting
meeting with one single partner so if
you're all thinking about sort of that
first check probably don't even think
about these guys this comes later in the
process when you're ready to raise a lot
of money the last kind of investor that
I can think of is crowdfunding websites
these are a little bit of a strange
thing to think about when it comes to
say a meeting or getting in front of
them because they split this
crowdfunding that can be done via
syndicate where there's one person who's
kind of like an angel who has a bunch of
money from other people to say hey we're
gonna invest in this thing and then
everyone follows them along they were
kind of like professional investors do
where you'll meet with them talk to them
then they'll say hey we're gonna back
you can we put you on there's private
syndicates in public and public
syndicates you do not have to meet with
every member of a syndicate in order to
raise money on a crowdfunding site and
there's also the option on any
crowdfunding sites to simply list your
company subject to a few checks to make
sure you're not committing fraud where
they'll just put you up and then people
will send money your way without you
ever meeting anyone this is a good way
to raise money if you can't figure out
another way to do it or there's no
investors near you or you don't want to
be bothered with the time it's usually
not a good way to raise lots and lots
and lots of money because one is usually
not there and to it if you have all
these
individual tiny little investors on your
cap table they become a nightmare to
manage so think carefully about this
option and think about what it will do
for you and what it can do to you so a
couple of these investors as I mentioned
are susceptible or open to receiving
cold emails actually everyone is
receptive to cold emails I think I
respond to pretty much every cold email
I get if I can but there's good ones and
bad ones so here's a bad cold email dear
sir or madam I have noticed in my
research on the Internet that you are an
investor in technology companies I'd
like to introduce you to an opportunity
to make money in this new and exciting
field may I come to your office for an
hour to present you with this
opportunity
sincerely Aaron I would not take a
meeting with this person I have no idea
what they do they don't seem to have
done any work to understand what I'm
interested in Who I am what I've done in
the past and they're asking for an hour
of my time in person that's a lot of
time remember that professional
investors sure there they meet with
people all day long but the only thing
that limits them is their time and so
they want to give that to the people who
matter most so how do you think about
sending a good cold email the answer is
by doing research most investors are
very happy to tweet about things that
interest them companies they've invested
in they write blogs about ideas that
they have in companies that they want to
see exist they have prolific profiles
online based on the companies that
they've started in the past you should
go and research every single investor
that you want to talk to and figure out
a way to get in front of them with a
custom introduction that is relevant to
them and to you so here's one you could
send to adora Oh Dora I'm building a
marketplace for home cleaners I have a
novel approach to this all of the
cleaners or robots we've launched and
are just starting to grow so let's stop
for a second if you've done research on
a Dora you know that she built a
marketplace for home services so
you know that this is relevant to her
you also might know she thinks robots
are cool so that's another good hook you
tell her the stage that you're at
launched and are just starting to grow
now launched is great because it proves
that you're actually doing things
starting to grow is intriguing because
it makes me want to ask how much are you
starting to grow how fast well how are
you measuring growth how do these things
work then I think you'd be a great
investor for us because of your
experience with homejoy
I think we've solved unit economics and
reliability can we discuss this for 15
minutes
happy email if that's better for you
sincerely Aaron so let's think of all
the different things here that are good
you've only asked for fifteen minutes of
time that's easy and can be done by the
phone you also offered to do it over
email if a Dora happens to be busy or is
traveling she can just deal with the
first set of questions over email I love
to do this I always go to email first
and if someone really gives good email
responses and is thoughtful and asks
good questions I'm much more inclined to
meet them and be happy when I'm meeting
them walk into the meeting with a
positive understanding of what they're
doing and context to understand the
entire conversation right that's a
that's a prepared mind for what you're
thinking of doing you reference her past
with homejoy
and you'll know if you watch some of
Edoras lectures and videos online that
she thinks a lot about unit economics
and reliability so you know that these
things are important and you're saying
we've solved these two key critical
issues that are important to you this is
a slam dunk right this is a cold email
that is likely to get a response whether
or not you know the person you're
emailing because it's so specific it's
the same thing by the way if you are
sending lots of email to people you
don't necessarily know to try to
convince them to use your service
there's a big difference between
spamming people right and sending them a
relevant email about a relevant service
that they will find interesting don't
spam investors it doesn't work they're
immune to it investors are not usually
sitting around waiting for an email from
someone they've never met introducing
them to an investment opportunity what
they are waiting
for is the company that no one else
knows that is secretly amazing that
nobody else has talked to yet that has
no connections that is the company that
if you find it and is actually as good
as it seems that's the one that makes
you all of the money so an investor who
gets a cold email this good is already
starting to think oh crap this is my
Google and no one else knows about it I
better move fast meet them figure out
what's going on give them a bunch of
money and then help them IPO that's the
response you want to get out of someone
in fact that that's what you want to
walk out of every meeting with an
investor who's excited to move on to the
next steps now as you move through
meetings with investors there are a
whole bunch of different meeting types
that you'll have to navigate and
different investors do different kinds
of these meetings so let me list them
and then I'll walk through a little bit
more about what they are first up
there's the intro meeting all investors
do intro meetings except the
crowdfunding sites then there's a
follow-up meeting pretty much all
investors do this except some angels who
might decide to invest in you after that
first meeting then you've got the
decision meeting this is really only
professional investors this will be a
meeting with multiple partners or with
that one partner but to really dig in
and make sure that they want to do the
deal after well depending on how
competitive your fund raises which is a
whole other set of things there's
diligence a diligence meeting might be
with you might be with your team might
be with your lawyer
sometimes it's handled by the VC
themselves or the investor themselves
and sometimes it's handled by someone on
their team and then finally if it all
goes according to plan you get fancy
dinners fancy dinners are the goal not
not raising money for your company
getting to eat for free
different investors will use fancy
dinners differently sometimes it's used
to sell you on an offer that they've
made where they really want to get to
know you better and show you how great
they are and then usually after that
everything's done you can finagle a
closing dinner out of someone it all
seriousness the the reason that I put
this on here is that every investor that
you take onto your cap table is going to
be with you for the life of your company
you need to make sure the people you're
taking money from aren't jerks if you
can't sit through an hour dinner with
someone you should think very carefully
about whether or not you want to take
their money this is a little less
relevant at very early stages with small
cheque size for small cheque sizes from
angels but anyone who's giving you a
material amount of money you need to
think very carefully about whether or
not you want them there all right what
you need for each of these meetings
changes the intro meeting is really
simple all you really need is a clear
explanation of your idea that's actually
the base level of everything a super
clear this is the elevator pitch right
the reason this is important is because
research shows that people make
decisions about what they want to do in
an interview sometimes in the first 30
seconds of a meeting right you can't
necessarily get to yes in 30 seconds but
you can often get to know and if someone
comes in and cannot explain what they do
that's a really bad sign so make sure
you really understand what it is that
you want to say and how you want to
explain it if you have a demo of what
you've built that's awesome investors
love to engage with real products and
see and not only do they want to see
that because they love playing with
things this is evidence that you are
doing the things that you were saying
you're gonna do the entire purpose of
meeting with investors is to show them
that you are inevitably going to be
gigantic and progress is critical to
that I would also recommend having a
reasonably clean shirt does it have to
be spotless I understand what it's like
to be a founder but don't show up
looking like you just rolled out of bed
all rumpled you can get away with that
sometimes but again people unfortunately
judge based on first impressions if you
walk into the room looking like you
don't give a crap about the meeting the
investor isn't gonna give a crap about
the meeting if you get past the intro
you're gonna get to a follow-up meeting
again except for the Angels that invest
off the first meeting follow-ups start
to dig a little more deeply into your
business so you need to understand your
metrics now in some cases this will be
the metrics that your business already
has and in other cases it'll be the
metrics that your company will have in
the future so if you're building a
consumer business but you haven't
launched yet you need to have a
framework for understanding that monthly
actives are important to you or weeklies
or Daly's or hourly actives are
important to you and talk about how
you're thinking about those things and
how you're gonna focus on them you need
to be able to explain your progress up
to now and remember that progress is in
an absolute value progress is slope how
long have you been working on what
you're working on and how far have you
gotten in that time if you've been
working on something for five years and
have yet to launch not great if you've
been working on it for a month and have
a prototype ready that's amazing so it's
all relative and you want to be able to
dig a little more deeply on your
insights into why you're doing what
you're doing then you did in that first
introduction meeting remember that that
introduction meeting can be 15 minutes
it could be an hour but it's probably
pretty short so this is your chance to
show just how much you understand about
what you're doing when you get to an
actual decision meeting this is really
when you need the deck again this is
mostly for professional investors most
angels don't need to see a deck it's not
really that relevant I kind of think
that some people spend more time on
their deck than they do working on
product which is usually a bad trade
because customers don't generally buy
decks some do but that's just weird so
you need to have your deck and the deck
doesn't have to be long actually the
simpler the deck the better this deck is
really really long that I'm running
through today if you're a seed company
eight slides maybe
10 your opportunity your team what
you're gonna build or what you've
already built and your early metrics
that's it I actually put up a sample
slide deck on though on the YC blog go
check it out it's really short you can
actually just use that deck and replace
your name with the deck company I think
is what it's called at this point if you
have metrics you need to know them cold
if someone asks you what six month or 12
months retention is know it off the top
of your head don't have to pull up your
computer and look for it obviously there
are levels and layers of metrics
underneath that you don't need but any
top-level metric that's important know
that and for your most important metrics
be able to dig in a couple layers the
critical part of a decision meeting and
again this is because this is for
professional investors is that you need
to take where you are now and project
what the biggest future actually is I
remember when I sat down and pitched
Sequoia for my decision meeting like me
and five partners in the room and the
thing that they really dug in on was
what my company could be in 10 or 15
years and that was all they cared about
at that point they were already sold on
the basics of the business at that point
they were sold mostly on me but the
thing that they wanted to understand I
think is how I thought about the future
and whether or not they thought I could
actually do that thing could we become a
globe spanning company because again
that's the only thing they care about
and your ability to dig into that and
explain it is the difference between
whether or not you're just another
company or something with huge vision
that they think you can achieve after
that comes the diligence meetings these
meetings aren't usually that hard on you
if you've done your homework ahead of
time and again this is later the earlier
in your life as a company the less
diligence you have make sure you have
your legal docs in order make sure your
financials if you have them make sense
we've seen some really insane things
come up during diligence where a company
has you know 50% less cash than they
thought they did don't do that it's
usually some other problems at work if
that happens and have a metrics
dashboard again if you have the metrics
be able to bring up your full dashboard
so that people can really do
way down into everything that you're
doing so if you walk through all of
those things if you understand the
framework for your meetings you'll get
to the final step which is that fancy
dinner there is food and you'll need
another reasonably clean shirt but this
is the end and doesn't even necessarily
happen and honestly even if it doesn't
the thing that you were trying to get to
is actually money in the bank whether or
not an investor takes you out for a meal
or an investor seems fancy or other
people think the investor is cool none
of that matters right at the end of the
day the thing that you need as a company
if you need money to grow is just money
and honestly all of these meetings are
irrelevant if you can get that money
without them so never put yourself in a
position where an investor that you have
researched is great you know they're
great they email you and say hey I'm
traveling this month but I really want
to invest can I send you a quarter of a
million dollars and we'll catch up
afterwards don't say no because you
haven't met for coffee right I'd
recommend getting on the phone with them
and chatting with them and trying to do
your own diligence right check
references but don't turn people down
just because they haven't fit into
whatever we believe or you believe is
the perfect process a few things to
remember about meetings about investors
most importantly meetings do not equal
progress I run into so many founders who
tell me all about all of the different
meetings that they're having and how
they met with this person and that
person in that famous person it's
irrelevant the only thing that matters
is building a big company and if you are
meeting with investors when you don't
need to raise money you are taking your
time and focus away from the thing that
matters which is building the big
company so only start meeting with
investors when you know that you need
money when you are in a fundraising
process the only thing that counts as a
yes I will invest is yes I will invest
signed documents and wired money
investors hate saying no because every
time they say no they closed off the
opportunity to invest in something
that's going to make them a lot of money
and they risk looking stupid for having
said no so they will do everything they
can not to what I've actually found is
the best investors are the ones who will
say no fastest not say yes fastest who
will say no fastest because they're the
ones who understand what it is they're
looking for and how to make decisions
quickly and if you find yourself in a
situation you're going on meeting after
meeting after meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting after
meeting after meeting nothing takes that
long right this is a gamble and at some
point someone has to make a decision and
indecisive investors you usually don't
make good decisions so when you're
meeting with people push to a close the
final piece is a warning for you to
watch out for I hate having to talk
about these things because I wish they
didn't happen but they do the first
piece of bad behavior is what I just
mentioned investors who just waste your
time this is honestly kind of harmless
but just watch out for it the next thing
is investors who are jerks
this takes lots of different forms there
are investors who will try to impress
you with how much money they have who
will try to impress you with the people
they know who will talk down to you
because you're new and they're old
they're investors who will try to make
you feel as if your idea is stupid
without giving you any help or
understanding of where their thought
process is coming from don't take it if
someone's a jerk leave or say hey you're
being an [ __ ]
I have a lot of people that I can talk
to and I'd rather not talk to you thanks
don't be a jerk yourself but be honest
before thright and leave a meeting if
you have to if someone's being a jerk
don't take another meet with them then
tell your friends that this person was a
jerk to you
this behavior corrects itself pretty
quickly now sometimes people are being
jerks without realizing it they just
think that's what they're supposed to do
or they're not so good in social
interactions try giving feedback if that
happens and see what happens there
investors who will meet with you just to
do diligence on you for one of their
portfolio companies this is usually
pretty obvious because they'll just ask
you question after question after
question after question about like
process and metrics and who your
suppliers are and who your special
relationships are and what are their
phone numbers and when can they go see
them and can they introduce you to
someone else who seems to be working on
a competitive product but no don't worry
it's not really a competitive product oh
wait wait wait a second so before you
meet with someone just check to see if
they are already invested in competitors
and talk to them about it ahead of time
for a lot of investors they explicitly
say we're happy to invest in competitors
over time and we compartmentalize
information actually YC does this we are
happy to invest in competitors we
sometimes do it in the same batch we
tell both companies were doing it but
we'll do in the same batch and we'll do
it across batches and we've developed a
system whereby we're very careful about
what information can or would be shared
and violating that trust is something
keeping that trust secret is something
that we are very serious about the last
thing and this has importantly become an
issue is harassment
this could be sexual harassment it could
be racism it could be any kind of
bigotry
unfortunately wealth has absolutely no
relationship to morality right and
investors some of them are not good
people
I'll say most of the investors that I
interact with regularly are great but
there are some bad apples and we just
released a report this week talking
about just how many YC founders have
experienced sexual harassment the
numbers were way higher than I would
have possibly imagined so if you
encounter anything like this
this is absolutely grounds to walk right
out no one should ever be allowed to
make you feel as if you have to do
anything for them to get their money
other than build a big company no one
should ever be allowed to violate your
personal space or make you feel
uncomfortable if it happens walk away
and tell us we're starting to get better
at dealing with this and we would much
prefer a situation in which no investor
meeting ever goes in a way where someone
ends up feeling uncomfortable so that's
how to think about investor meetings
kind of think about when you need them
how to get them who to do them with and
how to do them I really think that if
you follow these steps everything will
always go perfectly for you at least I
hope it does thank you all so much and I
think we have time for questions
yeah is it wise to approach if you see
who has already invested in a competitor
it's incredibly case dependent if they
invested in a competitor ten years ago
that company is public they might
actually be a perfect investor for you
because they know the playbook and
they'll help you I Pio but you need to
just look at the specific situation and
decide whether or not it makes sense
between the seed funds the angel funds
and the micro VCS I don't even talk
about micro VCS I'm never sure what they
are what's the average check size and
round size it's some dependent not just
on its dependent there's so many
variables the investors the market the
geography the company and what it needs
I mean there are seed rounds that get
done for $50,000 and seed rounds that
get done for ten million dollars so it's
it's really dependent I think the way to
think about it is more what do I need
smaller funds or most smaller funds and
angels are most likely to write small
checks somewhere between I don't know
ten and a hundred thousand dollars and
larger funds are beyond that
we gave you the garbage how do you
figure out which angels are credible ask
them for references look at their
portfolios angel list usually if
someone's an active angel angellist
usually records what they do and what
they've invested in and again angels who
are really active tend to talk about it
a lot
not for a bad reason actually by talking
about it that's how they get deal flow
right if you know someone's an active
angel you're going to approach them so
you should be able to do some amount of
diligence obviously this is harder in
emerging markets where there isn't as
hell like as large of an investor
ecosystem but you just have to do the
footwork to figure it out
[Music]
can I talk about the mechanics of
investor FOMO or fear of missing out
that would be a whole hours worth of
conversation
the basic idea though is investors
investors want to invest in the largest
companies they possibly can and get as
much ownership as they possibly can but
at the early stages of a start-up
there's very little data to say whether
or not this company is likely to succeed
and so investors are always looking for
other pieces of confirmatory data
essentially one of the most powerful
pieces of that data set is whether or
not other smart people seem to think
this is a good idea
and so the reason FOMO exists is because
if you see other smart investors getting
in on something you infer that that
company is good and likely to be big and
you don't want to miss out on that and
so that's why a lot of investors sit
back and wait for someone else to make
the move I think those are generally the
less good investors again the best
investors really are the ones who make
their own decisions faster than anyone
else and actually the best investors are
the ones who have incredibly fast
diligence processes so they are the ones
way out ahead of everyone
you can still pressure them a little bit
by having other investors lined up
behind so they know that they have to
move quickly but that's the shortest
possible answer I could give you on it
mistakes that founders often make while
communicating vision some go too big in
a way that makes them seem scattered so
if I were to pitch you on a company that
is well or a search engine we also have
self-driving cars we make phones
speakers we built this crazy balloon
that beams the internet down we have ads
and display ads and artificial
intelligence and a whole department that
just works on
crazy ideas you'd say oh this is a lot
even for me
right so that's kind of going too big
it'll it'll make you seem scattered on
the other side but sometimes people go
too small and they say well if we're
gonna conquer 10% of our market that's
worth 50 million dollars and we're
getting a hundred percent of it okay
then what okay so there has to be there
there that isn't too wild
those are think are sort of the two
extremes to think about how do you pitch
family and friends who can't afford to
lose money no I think that's very
dependent on your relationship with
those friends and family you know if I
wanted Jeff to give me money I'd camp
out outside of his house and show up
every morning with doughnuts and coffee
I think that would get to him pretty
well that was seriously I think it
really depends on who it is I'd
recommend working on an elevator pitch
maybe even a deck just for practice
right that's the friendliest audience
you're ever going to get now this is
different by the way if your friends and
family happen to be incredibly
successful founders who know what
they're doing or venture investors then
you can use them as real practice and
say hey here's how I'm planning on
building my business you built a
business does this make sense
so as much ask for advice as much as
you're asking for money in that case and
and really just treat it like a
professional interaction
[Music]
we have do we have to drop everything
we're doing for fundraising and if so
how long pretty much yes you're either
fundraising or you're working on your
company which is why you shouldn't try
to fundraise unless you need it and for
how long is however long it takes I mean
I mean you should be prepared to take
six months a year I mean it it really
depends now if it's if you are a very
early-stage company and it's taking you
a year to fundraise and you're not
working on your product for a year
that's probably pretty bad right that
means you're not making any progress so
I wouldn't do that but again this is a
question of figuring out whether or not
you really need money if you're just
starting out you try to raise money for
a month or two no one's giving you money
I'd say try to figure out how to grow
without without raising anything and
then come back later
[Music]
sorry some investors will only fund
women founders what I think of that yeah
I think that's great
I think that if the way that I think
about fundraising and company building
in generals press every unfair advantage
that you have this is like this is a
corrective narrative where there's
investors who are specifically trying to
fund female founders because investors
have been pretty bad at that in the past
and if you can use that to your
advantage you absolutely should I think
it's great should all founders be
focused on the fundraising process no
this is the CEOs job if you are lucky
enough to have co-founders who can do
other things have them do other things
again that will help you not completely
stop progress on the business
while you're while you're fundraising
right if you can you want to keep
pushing the business forward while the
CEO goes and fundraisers with the
professional investors with the venture
investors for later larger later rounds
they're eventually going to want to meet
the entire team but they don't need it
at the beginning and in fact you
shouldn't bring the entire team to
meetings for the following reason if you
are in an investor meeting and someone
makes you an offer if the entire team is
there you have to make a decision on the
spot but you're at a severe disadvantage
there because professional investors
professionally negotiate and make offers
you've probably never done this before
and the rest of your team is back home
you can say thank you so much for that
offer it's really interesting I need to
talk about it with my co-founders and
then you can go back and talk to your
co-founders and buy yourself some time
to really think through the plusses and
minuses thank you all
you
you